so here's a new rule to live by if you
ever and I mean ever come across those
anime 40K 60 frames per second type
videos on Tick Tock Twitter Youtube or
wherever run how are they awful you
might be asking well I mean where to
start it's not the 4K that's the worst
part it's 60 frames per second
you're looking at two frames then
guessing what will come in between and
spoiler alert it is not a very good
guesser call me a hater all you want but
this is going to haunt my nightmares and
honestly there's a million other issues
like destroying the pacing of a given
animated section by interpolation
temporal stabilization and plenty of
other issues that I can get into but
what's important to remember here is
that this new rule for you is not just
the ramblings of some Irish whack job
this is the universal consensus of every
single professional in the animation
industry